défiler des étudiants de la Faculté de
Médecine pour mardi gras ce 12 février
comme chaque année les étudiants se sont
déguisés et ont arpenté les rues de 50
ans en Yvelines bananes et princesses
chacun est libre de sa vie comme il le
souhaite une seule action obligatoire
faire entendre sa voix en chantant
le carnaval de médecine un rendez-vous
immanquable pour ses étudiants
chez nous c'est une tradition c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait chaque année
c'est vraiment sympa on est tous
déguisés il y a vraiment une bonne
ambiance
les étudiants de première et deuxième
année de médecine n'ont pas hésité à
rentrer dans les salles pour suspendre
les cours des autres filières une
journée de bonne humeur donc qui permet
de faire oublier la pression de la fac
il y a tellement de pression ça fait du
bien un jour dans l'année de d'oublier
toute la sélection tout ça et de passer
un bon moment quoi c'est important de
décompresser on travaille tellement que
il y a des moments forcément et puis
c'est bien c'est enfin c'est une
histoire de fac après tout le monde se
connaît tout ça donc c'est sûr c'est
agréable un carnaval qui a entraîné des
perturbations dans le déroulé des cours
certains professeurs ayant choisi de
quitter leurs amphis à la vue des
étudiants des billets